gregorio asked we've migrated our  containers from virtual machines to  cloud run to reduce ops work how do i  monitor cpu load and memory usage on  serverless  my answer is you don't have to if your  cloud run instances start hitting high  cpu load google cloud will automatically  spin up new instances for you and vice  versa no action required by you  now think about new metrics that are  more meaningful to your business than  cpu load monitor metrics like these and  your business folks will love you  one way to get started is to click  log-based metrics in the google cloud  console  another is to export your logs to  bigquery and build a pretty data studio  dashboard on top of that  and if you're like me and you're curious  about cpu load and memory usage you can  still find them under the metrics tab in  cloud run  let me know your questions about google  cloud serverless in the comments